oh it kind of it looks fun i'm just
gonna go
for it oh i didn't get i didn't add
water hey inga
what's up you ready to do another kid
science experiment
i am ready
have you heard of elephant toothpaste i
have only heard of it because i saw this
like viral video where this guy
made like one that was huge and it just
like yes
went up into the sky yes it looks cool
it's very fun the only problem is we
don't have instructions on how
to make it we just have the ingredients
so
inga and i are going to see who can make
elephant toothpaste
divide us do you know why it's called
elephant toothpaste
it's just such a large amount of
toothpaste it must be for an elephant
i'm pretty sure there's no more logic to
it than that
okay we're gonna have about 10 minutes
to put this together
all right let's do this
all right i'm gonna put these on because
we're dealing with chemicals here
so we have some old friends here
like this little guy and this as inga
and i
try to complete this 5th grade science
experiment
oh wait i don't i don't want to do that
yet actual kid experts
are going to tell you how you actually
make elephant toothpaste this is what
you need
hydrogen peroxide yeast dish soap food
coloring
a little hot water and then a flask
first you need 240 milliliters of
hydrogen peroxide
okay so next we're going to do 60
milliliters of dish soap
[Music]
oh i didn't measure that pour the
hydrogen peroxide dish soap and food
coloring into the bottle
i think the yeast is the rising agent
i don't cook really so i think yeast i
think yeast infection
next in the separate container now we're
going to make 7.5 milliliters of
active use with a little hot water then
give it a little time
at least five minutes
[Music]
you know what it smells like a beer
i feel like it's not activating the
right way they probably don't tell you
that when you're a kid because
they don't want you thinking about beer
as a fifth grader
okay i'm just gonna test this out i
don't know if this is gonna give me
anything you're doing a mini test right
now
okay i'm gonna do a mini test too do i
just need
more quantities of stuff wait
wait it's going up it's slowly
and that's a really good sign so are you
about ready to do it
yeah i'm gonna do the actual thing now
finally pour the yeast mixture into the
bottle
and then you got elephant toothpaste
ready
and go go
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't that was like a toothpaste
that was like a toothpaste right
you can keep adding color to it i think
too oh wait really
yeah wait this is the coolest thing ever
oh my god look at that you guys
oh man honestly inga i feel like this is
the closest to correct i've gotten and
it was mostly because you said the thing
about you still the beginning activating
so how does the chemical reaction
behind elephant's toothpaste work well
the hydrogen peroxide it slowly breaks
down into oxygen and water
okay and to make the reaction happen
faster
we add a catalyst yeast the oxygen gas
turns into bubbles
and bubbles plus dish soap will make it
foamy and that's how you make
elephant toothpaste all right well i
think inga and i
learned a lot hopefully now you guys can
make elephant toothpaste at home
even if you're a dum-dum adult like us
alright
bye
[Music]
you